foreign
[Music]
I'm surprised to see here in my office
you not so much Yakuza but Gerald
surprised nobody's punched you in the
mouth okay I know tensions are a little
high right now so I'll let that slide
Rick get to the point Sammy well I've
had time to go over your proposal for
the new show and
I can't approve this in any way shape or
form you guys brought me in you got a
bunch of new shows I'm just trying to
help the network grow what's wrong with
that yeah what's wrong with that
Poindexter let me read you your proposal
please all right I'm going to tell you
it starts off as I quote like a game
show and stuff like Fear Factor meets
The Price is Right I already want to
watch it damn that sounds good meets The
Price is Right and the Running Man the
main game is Plinko only instead of
discs it has one of those circular Buzz
saw things instead of the disc uh
landing on the prize it lodges itself
firmly into someone's skull it's
existential yet accessible and people
love high stakes Sam it's murder it's
comedy I'm not gonna waste everyone's
time here sticking around any longer no
I'll tell you what you can't do Sam
can't grow facial hair at 35. oh that's
low that is really no you're low you're
short I am not sure Casey
an inch I'm trying to get this out like
is it the short thing that's causing
this to be a problem that you can't
speak
you're short it's glandular
we'll call it running Plinko no you want
yes
[Music]
they don't want you talking about it
they don't want you discussing it people
just want to laugh if it's funny it's
funny I'm gonna just start being Who I
Really Am what do you think constitutes
racism in comedy Nick you're up for the
love of God I think that's a big reason
for the changing landscape and comedy
someone is already tweeting how angry
they are and I don't care
you start to realize there are lines
you're willing to defend now you have
all of these alt Comics it's sad I don't
have you know I get a lot of black fans
yeah I haven't met any of them yet but
welcome to murderer's room
[Music]
[Applause]
would I know
foreign
[Music]
smooth transition there that was nice
that was good that transition with the
audio and the Sip is that perfect
it was like a symbiotic sip intro glad
to be with you
Monday you said Murderers Row a lot of
you asked for it you're going to get
more of that money and then we have the
the mega live stream on uh on Wednesday
Wednesday yeah more debates so tune in
for that what time does it start that
time o'clock we'll figure it out are you
drunk no I'm not drunk at all I don't
think you were still alive level three
help me with the time so we have a I
would say there's a lot to get to but
here's the thing there's actually not
there's one kind of through line here
that we're going to be dealing with it's
that your government isn't looking out
for you they don't care about you and a
lot of questions have been answered
regardless of where you line up on the
Russell Brand issue and regardless of
what you think about people fleeing a
crappy country to come to a better
country namely Mexico crappy country
America a better country uh before I get
to any of that actually I should say I
don't even know if that constitutes a
reason but uh if you're watching on
YouTube and you see this
head on over to rumble I don't know if
I'm allowed to say that Mexico is a bet
I don't want to vilify an entire nation
of people that's fine but Mexico's a
horrible place there you go okay
so Russell Brand this is happening right
now you know the UK Parliament sent a
message out to rumble
asking them to remove Russell Brand and
to X formerly Twitter I still call it
Twitter
this is not about private companies can
we all agree comment below hit like when
people say it's a private company man
the Libertarians out there who think
that they're they're being Pious it's
not a private company we have a why do
you think YouTube removed Russell Brand
yeah you think that you think UK
Parliament sent a message to rumble and
not YouTube Michael
now you know conservatives stop
appeasing crocodiles and we're also
going to be talking about the uh the
Border let's call it what it is a border
Invasion right now record numbers
questions have been answered hey we're
bringing in votes so we want to shut
down voices that disagree with the
government that go against the
government narrative and we want to
bring in people who are now reliant on
Big Daddy government uh who by the way
commit record numbers of crimes against
you the American citizens your
government really only exists to protect
you to protect your freedoms to protect
you from physical threats meaning
invasions meaning being physically
harmed and to protect your rights like
your right to speak freely
they are attacking both
that's what we're going to be talking
about today also Emma Roberts is a
apparently pretty based very based which
is fine oh no so okay uh Gerald uh it's
just it's it's remarkable to me you know
we saw this with Rumble and I could not
be prouder by the way louder with
crowder.com of course we are partnered
with Rumble my club is an umbrella under
Rumble where you subscribe uh to mug
club and you get Nick de Paulo you get
Brian Callan you get Alex Jones on
Friday you get our extra show every day
you get our extra Friday show we're
going to have Hodge twins soon you have
Mr guns and gear all of that is under
the umbrella of Rumble if you just click
the button while you're watching on
Rumble right now and you join mug Club
you get to continue watching seamlessly
as though you never left
um and I couldn't be happier with a
response from the CEO of Rumble I know
that's like not tastic I'm not patting
myself in the back but Chris Chris over
there at Rumble good for you nailed it
brass balls Gerald
hey number two CEO how are you I'm
fantastic also not drunk no oh yeah
you're just slightly inebriated no
slightly anybody here he's not drunk
he's Buzz I'm not at all and then when
you hear this
[Music]
you know who it is uh he's going to be
the Genesee Theater in Waukegan Illinois
it's a silly Place Sunday September 24th
and you can see the rest of his tour
dates at briancallen.com Mr Kellen how
are you I'm a man just uh fresh off the
squat rack Steven so my testosterone is
a little high which means I'll be a
little extra right wing today possibly
good just a warning to everybody just a
warning that means that when women go
off their birth control they're going to
leave their men for you
it's a pheromone a pheromone it's a
pheromone thing and it's only gay if
you're smiling yeah so no no no no it's
I don't know how many rules go look in
the eyes is that what it is you don't
make eye contact it's fine I always
stare at the wall yeah right that's why
at the squat rack doesn't actually do
that too you have to actually squat
that's why Gone Girl is so creepy
because she looks in the eyes when she
yeah that that mess that messed me up
for a while I know I was just thinking
about being spotted on the squat rack
make sure you secure my hips oh with
those big D1 hands you were thinking
about that I was thinking about the
attractive lady in Gone Girl oh yeah me
too me too peer pressure so I've had all
this straight talk before we get to uh
sorry before we get to the issues uh
here that we'll be talking about today
and I know a lot of people have been
talking about Russell Brand On the
Border but um I will tell you this our
rule is if well kind of first it's be
best we don't have to break so I'm gonna
get a scoop we want to be correct and
the information that we have now on
Russell Brand
uh as far as the sorry not Russell Brand
as far as the allegations out there but
the kinds of letters that have been sent
out from governments is unbelievably
disturbing but before that while we're
talking about government here's the
thing
I want you to know
that this is real
this m refer is real uh this clip this
is a Canadian Channel and these are
Canadian talk shows because I know what
you're this is a parody of like you know
morning show hosts in Canada slash low
rent podcast if you want to know the
descent into tyranny watch Canada and
look at the Liberals look at the
leftists in Canada now I say liberals
because I know some people say I'm a
classical liberal okay whatever in
Canada that's the actual political party
look at what they do and look at what
they would do if completely unfettered
now watch this talk show
with these two women in Canada who talk
about covid coming back here we go again
and there isn't even a portion in their
mind that thinks maybe there's a lack of
self-awareness this is real oh back on
stealing Vance and we're back to these
visuals Linda we got to get the arm flap
going you taught me
well I feel like a pin cushion I will be
there you call my name and I'm we're
getting that shot
um but I can't I thought lost track I
think I've had five have you had five I
actually yes and I've said I actually
got an extra one because the way it
timed out I had to get it before the new
one was whatever
hmm
wow I don't think so
we'll go back on steel out of my life
why am I keeping track of these they're
just gonna be able to get I'm like a
double Pfizer triple moderna now so I'm
going back to moderna or whatever I'll
take whatever you're gonna give me if
you're immunocompromised you should be
masking up now you need to be a little
bit more cautious it was the only thing
that I personally didn't really agree
with Dr Bonnie Henry on because she was
very very reluctant to mandate the kids
in classrooms how to wear masks because
she did not feel that they would be able
to tolerate it she admitted to us when
she was on the show nope actually the
kids handled that fairly well
I'll tell you what when I went to
Edmonton as I mentioned at the top of
the show my husband said we're wearing
Mouse on the plane and it was like yeah
you know what I'm not that comfortable
sitting in a tube with 250 other people
who I don't know in the middle of the
creeping up of covid so my husband and I
wore mass and there were
other people on the plane not a lot I
would say there was maybe like five of
us in the entire plane who were wearing
masks and just for a tiny second I felt
a little dramatic walking on then I
thought
actually don't care what you think of me
I don't know you you don't know me and I
don't care and I am sitting with people
literally a couple of feet in front
behind you can smell their hair right so
yeah you know I'm back to tucking a few
Mouse into the purse let's do it and I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna have to start
wearing them at Dad's Care Home Again
same
what
oh boy
oh
I'm gonna need just that
personal minute okay okay uh you know
Brian why don't why don't Brian why
don't you come over here he'll need just
he'll he'll be back he just he needs a
second yeah I got it
[Music]
yeah
there there is foreign
we're gonna need to order a new TV uh I
I think that was the appropriate
response though absolutely I think I
think sometimes it comes breaking thing
that's all you can do
it's a real pencil it's just one of
those broken in it
[Music]
there's a glass everywhere there's
glasses there's glass
I want to know what he did when he first
saw it radar oh my gosh well he just
smashed the TV literally the TV is way
broken he's probably he's probably on
the squat rack on the squat rack I was
just using right now just some of the
weight off taking a little of that out
bragging about the number of shots that
they've had bragging about the fact that
kids are now going to be back in masks
and there's okay he's back are you uh
you okay here you want your you want
your tea it's calming tea I think it's
got chamomile in it why don't you sit in
my seat third chair here so I can for
sure let's get some water you can feel
better Steven needs a little water
you're right there buddy there you go
there you go you do you do what you
needed to do
you go you do
you're 100 real video unreal that video
Guys these people this is when you
wonder hi hey there's no one who's going
to be Fooled Again by more lockdowns
they are not full they are absolutely
all for it by the way I love she's like
yeah I mixed them up a little bit I'm
double triple this guy that guy it
doesn't matter we don't need people like
you in our world I I really don't think
so so you mentioned this off the top one
of the things that we wanted to talk
about was uh was rumble's response to
what the UK Parliament said but if you
missed it uh yesterday uh Russell Brand
had faced some additional kind of
cancellations right and so we we saw
that we talked about the one on YouTube
where he was demonetized and they
actually sent a letter to both Tick Tock
and Rumble
um asking them basically pressuring them
to demonetize Russell Brand for
allegations things that haven't been
proven uh no convictions have come down
yet but they felt compelled to send this
letter anyway so I'm going to read to
you just a little bit over here we'd be
grateful if you would confirm whether Mr
bran is able to monetize his content we
would like to know whether Rumble
intends to join YouTube in suspending Mr
Brand's ability to earn money on the
platform
wow the the government of the UK one of
their citizens who has not been
convicted of any crimes
only allegations only in the Press has
come out and sent letters they didn't
just say this right this wasn't
something out of water please Water by
the way guys it's okay we don't need to
ruin the vibe in the room I'm just I'm
gonna
you'll be okay I've grew up around those
people in Canada well that's why you
look by the way these are the people who
will cheer this exactly cheer this
Brian earlier in the when we were
doing just go and run through Brian was
like do you think do you think
what
[Laughter]
what they thought they'd have a better
shot at shaking down Rumble when people
say private company here you go private
company there you go controlled by the
state yeah exactly company controlled by
the state absolutely you know you were
talking about how important um freedom
of speech is due process is just as
important it's gone without due process
what happens is you can just tell a
story about somebody and they lose
everything do you remember the Soviet
Union when you wanted somebody's
apartment and you just called the
authorities and said this guy was saying
something bad about the government yeah
and they were shipped off to the gulag
that that's a real thing oh no it's
existed for all of time now this is
absolutely 100 a real thing I know what
you're thinking like rated his apartment
and stole his lowest jeans
I wear low jeans because I've got great
obliques lowest lowest it's different
but I think you don't always have to
make it about your hips brought it back
to myself okay fine but this is the
government of the UK reaching out and
doing this again like I said this isn't
a political speech where they're
advocating for it which would be bad
enough this is actually a letter sent
straight to these companies and there is
only one response that they should get
from these companies and I'm
guaranteeing you right now that Tick
Tock won't respond this way I'm
guaranteeing you right now that YouTube
obviously did not respond this way this
is how you do it this is Rumble CEO
Chris pavlovsky he said today you do
today we received an extremely
disturbing letter here's why this is
important
this little this little bastard Chris
pavlovsky is Canadian yeah we just
watched those Canadian hags right that's
what he was that's what he was born and
bred with and by the way of course
hopefully he realizes a little Blaster
is a compliment yeah this this this this
Bo evil Chris pavlovsky this guy who was
raised in a in a in a nanny State
sweater vest police censorship FCC
decided that he was going to
start a company and flip them the birds
so you need to understand how how much
of a change that is for a guy like this
who was Canadian because he just saw
what it's like in that country so for
him to stand up and when we have people
on the right we have people in the on
the biggest conservative networks who
don't because they got to get the
YouTube dollar dollar bills that's
what's enraging Chris pavlovski balls of
steel go support that guy and thank God
for rumble all right absolutely so his
his quote today we received an extremely
disturbing letter from a committee chair
in the UK Parliament we regard it as a
deeply inappropriate and dangerous that
the UK Parliament would attempt to
control who is allowed to speak on
platform or to earn a living from doing
so
singling out an individual and demanding
his ban is an even more disturbing given
the absence of any connection between
the allegation and his content on Rumble
that's a really important point he is
saying specifically I have a lot of
problems with what you're asking me to
do but this guy didn't do anything on
our platform that is in any way related
to this and now you're coming after him
here although it may be politically and
socially easier for rumble to join a
cancel culture mob doing so would be a
violation of our company's values and
Mission we emphatically reject the UK
parliament's demands so basically I
don't think so with cuss words let me
distill this in French for you let me
give you a perfect example of remember
I've always said that YouTube uh they
actually they don't follow the law and
then they create their own law so for
example single party consent you know
that's what allows for investigative
journalism and it has to there's a
reason that that law exists otherwise
you would never have uh you know you
would never have Watergate for example
which by the way is Child's Play
compared to now but you can't expose
corruption YouTube says no hold on a
second the person who was filmed even if
they consent and they don't need to
consent oh no they don't want it now so
we're going to remove it so there you go
you can now remove that voice then they
create their own new laws and new rules
that oh wait you were accused of
something somewhere in the media so
we're going to remove this think about
this for a second
Mike Tyson and by the way this is not at
all to admonish Mike Tyson right I think
that Mike Tyson if you read his book
like Mike Tyson also had some really
tough breaks and I think that he was he
did some things that he admits to but he
was falsely maligned in a lot of ways
however this was a guy was convicted of
serious crimes and was put in prison
yeah okay in other words there was more
due process there for as much as the
judicial system offers due process
couldn't be on hot boxing with Mike
Tyson so you could have Mike Tyson and
Sammy the
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Mike Tyson yeah and then Alex Jones went
and filmed it with him and then the Alex
Jones released it on his own platform
because they were afraid to host Alex
Jones people were afraid to host Donald
Trump by the way before any indictments
just to be clear and Russell Brand so
actual criminals yeah actual criminals
they get they have True Crime shows
basically Brett and I'm not saying Mike
Tyson I'm just doing that because that's
a very prominent example but you have
actually no criminals on YouTube and
then people who've never been convicted
of a crime and you have the governments
reaching out to Big Tech to do their
bidding are you starting to get the
picture yeah and don't just look at Mana
don't look at monetization just as loss
of money that is that is enough that is
enough like you've talked about going to
war over somebody's ability to make a
living right we've gone to war over that
kind of stuff it's also reach
monetization affects your reach as well
if you're not monetized yeah your voice
doesn't get out there so they don't have
to quite ban you they can Shadow venue
they can demonetize you they can just
strike you every once in a while it's
kind of sounding a little familiar to me
about the emails that we receive yes
about stuff this is a really important
point it is about reach and according to
Glenn Greenwald these journalists didn't
have women come to them no no no they
went they went they went and found this
story themselves why now what what what
was it that they that caused them to go
out and like what he's saying thank you
yeah they don't like what he's saying
look and I want you guys to comment what
is Rumble standing up for free speech
mean to you because when people do step
out like go if whatever platform you are
on I'm sure that uh Rumble put it out
there Chris put it out there make sure
that you go out there and support him
make sure that you go out there and
reach tweet and comment and encourage
look Rumble has to be the Pirates
flicking off the rest of the industry or
they're nothing right that's exactly
what they're doing right here they're
standing up for free speech I'm still
waiting on Twitter's response yeah we
have that yet I don't think Twitter
pirate analogy though right now
they're good Pirates yeah but if they
don't want to be a pirate well good
Pirates do rape
yes can we all agree guys don't leave me
out here on the Viner to be a good
pirate you have to rape yes I'll leave
you on the plank yeah gotcha yeah right
let's stay it wouldn't be a pirate
otherwise you wouldn't be a pirate
otherwise what are you you're just a guy
in a funny with a funny how about this
privateers okay good there we go we can
do that they're they're basically
privateers all right do you have
something for me over there you're
gesticulating wildly I'm just pointing
my finger up all right yeah no uh
Guardian UK is actually saying this
Russell Brands Wonderland the online
soapbox where the star pushes his quote
free speech
[Music]
pushes
yeah his free speech he thinks that he
is he thinks that he's entitled to new
process he thinks he has the right to
actually speak as a it's the free speech
thing again right they do that with the
Second Amendment like oh yeah the Second
Amendment means that you can have any
gun you want so long as you're a lot of
body this doesn't erase the fact that
it's a shitty argument dummy
free speech is the line guys it goes it
all goes sorry it look around the world
where it doesn't exist you don't see
Freedom you see it here you see Freedom
that's being eroded unfortunately right
now but free speech and I don't care
what you think of the situation with
Russell Brand right now he should have
the ability to speak his reach should
not be limited he has not broken any
laws by the way I think the same applies
for Alex Jones of course same thing that
we've mentioned just a minute ago this
guy should be back on the platforms we
need a good reason why he's not and we
haven't gotten that yet I don't think we
ever will I think they're just gonna say
nope it's it really is an incestuous
relationship where what what disappoints
me most is not we've talked about this
it's not that big Tech does what they do
what would have broken my heart
genuinely would have been if Chris Chris
pavlovsky capitulated so I was that was
really something yes it can cost him not
only Revenue like he I don't know what
kind of position he has as far as
ownership and making sure that he's
protected not being ousted from a
company by a board or something like
that but it can cost him being able to
be there this is not the first time
they've done this they flicked off
France entire government right the
entire government with one finger that's
pretty good yeah nice job for a Canadian
right it's flip off yeah flick and it
took France a while to realize that they
had been uh they'd been bodied because
they were on a long weekend they were
yeah it was the month of August they
take that off work week what is this he
just gave he went like this between his
Alliance what does this means oh that
you are that's a big bag you were in
this hole
did you know that uh Julia Roberts had
had a niece that acted I didn't know
this oh my God I really didn't Emma
Roberts I didn't really
[Music]
it is you know that's enough let's you
know like get back to work and
she then looks at me and she goes she
goes don't you mean lady and she turns
around like this and covers her mouth
and goes back here
but can't see I'm looking at her dead
ass in the camera like what did you just
say
narcissist yes and I'm standing there
look at her dead ass that's a woman and
I'm like trying to process the
just say it
say it say it
beat her up I'm like I'm standing there
and she walked away
my blood is boiling that's a woman well
that's because of all the that's because
of all the the hormones that you're
taking symptoms
[Music]
foreign
salt right so I like that I'm I'm with
that but also uh she apparently mocked
Ross's voice a little bit so here's this
is kind of funny this is look if you're
gonna make a stand in Hollywood do it in
a fun and exciting way if it's gonna be
like your last hurray and they're going
to kick you off the set and you're never
gonna work again make sure it's a joke I
like it all right so here here's the
quote we're all sitting around and I'm
copying Cody's accent didn't know he had
one well then how the hell are you
copying it Emma then copies my voice and
laugh and drops it several octaves I was
shook first off the impressive thing is
Emma Roberts must have serious vocal
range
I love that she did that by the way
sitting around no fear whatsoever making
these comments in front of the director
sitting around doing this and by the way
just just so people know here's Angelica
when he was in the Navy yeah yeah yeah
okay by the way can you leave that up
for a second I mean looks more than
seven in in in the Navy well yeah I'm
actually just attracted to her I mean
him in the Navy oh my gosh you can't see
this vote with him I mean her what you
can't see this
I'm just saying he was very popular with
the sailors okay just some of the
sailors not all of the sailors yeah I'm
straight As Long As I don't think you're
in the eyes that I don't know how he was
in the village is this the prince rule
that you're talking about like you're
the one who came up with the rules I
can't follow all this all right bring
that back up do me a favor you can't
really see this if you can zoom in a
little bit that's fine but so it says
that uh I my soul Smiles because I know
myself in a Biblical manner I don't
understand if you know someone
biblically doesn't that imply sex it
depends on if it's old does this matter
trying to claim the God thing right
there like they'll always say this
though their arguments you know God
doesn't make any mistake I knew that I
was born a God doesn't make any mistakes
right and I'm born trans it's like well
hold on a second so you're saying so God
knew you you know before you were in
your mother's womb he numbered every
hair on your head you were fearfully and
wonderfully created like oh I forgot the
surgically removed the non-mistake and
then reopen it as a wound with a medical
device for like it's just it really is
gaslighting that's taking place from the
left it's like this is the way I was
made there are no mistakes no no no
plastic surgeon made you that way if
you're lucky but his hand was got his
scalpel was God
[Music]
thank you
oh
that was a god gorgeous I'm like a
Shayla look at that
[Laughter]
I know I love it though but uh
unfortunately Ross confirmed last night
that Roberts called
and apologized oh my God news came out I
didn't even know this part of the story
come on why there's an apology what you
weren't wrong it is a man you apologize
to the person who basically threatened
to kill you for a voice I looked and saw
her dead ass dead ass in the mirror and
then you're like I'm sorry I did do a
silly voice it did warrant a death
threat absolutely but we should say that
this is one of the few times that
somebody on the far left actually
accepts an apology
There's No Redemption for the most yeah
but going out and kind of trying to like
say this type of stuff in the media and
putting that stuff out there like
narcissist okay yeah she apologized but
let's hope that she doesn't ever work
again kind of stuff so I if that's the
way this apology comes across then
absolutely not but I understand what
you're saying so let me read the apology
real quick and see what they say so they
I didn't mean that uh thank you this is
the response is the response do we have
the apology I don't see the apology we
just have the response called and
apologized oh called and apologize okay
if you have the apology that would be
breaking the law
[Music]
it is that's I'm sorry that is when
people use the term that is the mob like
you know I appreciate I appreciate that
you are going to be an ally and I
appreciate that you want to walk on your
own two legs out of here and I
appreciate that you will say the things
that I want you to say if you value your
puppy
because it would be a shame it would be
a shame with a chick with a dick just
left a cyanide stake in your bush and oh
your puppy ain't there anymore so I
appreciate you being on board with the
lgbtq plus agenda
this is a Shakedown it is absolutely 100
do me a favor hit like if you think that
that Robert's apologizing is cowardly
right it's a coward's way out of this
you made two jokes that were funny that
we know of you probably made a lot more
that weren't reported on especially
behind the back of this person though
Gerald that her agent I know said if you
want to work again you better make this
right that's what happens and I know but
if you don't do this the UK Parliament
is going to give you a call as well and
I understand that and look I I agree I
understand that but you take the stand
that Chris pavlovski just did or you
don't make the joke yeah if you want to
continue to work you make this decision
beforehand you don't get to come back
afterwards because we know exactly where
you stand we know exactly what you
believe you said it and now you're
coming back and capitulating because you
think they aren't going to do this to
you they're not going to just kick you
out and not let you work again or maybe
they're not going to call you next time
they're thinking of a role it's not
going to happen I'm sorry eventually
it's going to go away the problem and I
understand what you're saying Brian
you're not advocating for it so I'm not
coming at you with it but look this this
is why these situations still exist in
the first place is because people do not
take a stand it will cost you something
to stand up for what you believe it will
absolutely cost you otherwise they're
not beliefs they're just ideas that's
right they just get molded to whatever
the society says Rumble stands up it
could cost them something something
meaning everything yeah especially if
the United States government follows up
with said request right it can cost them
everything it is worth more that you
stand up and say it because guess what
you've told us there's tons of people in
Hollywood that are conservative yeah
that are just too afraid to stand up
what if you all stood up at once that's
right what if you all said well you
define yourself you define yourself on
who you are under pressure under real
pressure when you could lose something
otherwise what are you worth you you
what what lines are you willing to
defend they would they would if they all
set up at once there'd be a lot of
Jewish Representatives tearing their
clothes a lot of money lost
the Jews probably they probably bought
off-brand clothing for the days they
knew they were going like let's wear
Champion it was all wait tomorrow's a
day where there's somebody where are the
Jews at Marshalls today it's Hebrews
Warehouse it was all a big grift by them
have you ever tried to tear up a close
person that says
we got strong fingers you got strong
tensile strengths I knew I should have
won the American Apparel huh
so look look at Old Navy is too boxy I
said
even though she did this apology look
all of the Lefty celebrities know that
this is a grip the trans agenda yes
there is it's nothing is going to be
enough right now it used to be about
gender-neutral bathrooms and now it's oh
you can't even do a voice and by the
Brian you know this here's the thing
whenever I tell a story I accidentally
do an impression you slip into yeah
people will say oh you're doing
Blackfish or oh you're doing Asian Voice
or oh you're doing Gerald Voice or it
doesn't matter what it is oh you're
doing lady voice that's what a lot of
people especially if you're a performer
it doesn't mean that there's any amount
there is no Grace anymore for the people
who claim that they want to be
empathetic it's all a game of gotcha
it's all a game of ruining people's
lives for a moment of maybe they didn't
even do something wrong they'll just
fabricate it anyway it and it extends to
everything and by the way gender neutral
bathrooms that's one that's how it
started the you would think they add
something more even in this office we've
had to deal with it that's not enough
[Applause]
[Music]
you know the American with Disabilities
Act it's there for a reason
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
there's no paper
I'm I'm just glad he finally found out
when you got to go you gotta go you know
so I just uh
when he's not using the telekinesis it's
I figured he would it's just a handicap
tried to yeah it really is I can I'll
expand that doorway I know a guy yeah
you know a guy that's fantastic look
guys it is a live show Monday through
Friday 10 a.m Eastern check us out here
on Rumble if you end up on YouTube make
sure you hit the like button do
something there to let the algorithm
know that we're still alive because they
like to uh you know just strike us every
once in a while for Content that's not
even on their platform I understand that
they love to do that with Russell Brand
as well uh and uh then make it appear
like we don't exist on there so go over
there for a second and then come right
back every once in a while I'll name
that movie man in a while all right so a
lot of you
um obviously have seen that there are
issues at the border right we've covered
this topic a number of times I want you
to understand this is a little different
we're going to talk about it in a
slightly different way than we have
before it's an invasion new information
yes it is yeah it's not a it's not a
small mundane detail now at the border
right
um the illegal Crossings are actually
surging again and a lot of people think
that it's this about this like racial
replacement I I think it's actually
about disintegrating and kind of blowing
up the middle class so the party that's
actually for the middle class the party
that always says therefore at least the
middle class is actually putting
policies into place that will blow up
the middle class and we're going to tell
you exactly how they're going to do that
but to kind of set this up thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
Venezuelan freeloaders are currently
pouring across that border into Texas
and there's a lot it's not Miss Universe
no
thank you
just want a free ride
it's getting wet
hola
and by the way to give CR to be fair
here before you get angry like let's
let's run the end of that clip again and
let's let's look at the there are some
Scholars yeah yeah right let's look at
that
there you go lawyer pediatrician
mechanical engineer okay wedding planner
nice landscaper and then there also is a
sex trafficker whoa in the back you
didn't even see that yeah I know yeah I
know well these are uh these are these
are kids these are families right yeah
the MSN you know Washington Post that's
that's the favorite thing that they like
to say these families they're fleeing
oppression they're they're fleeing all
of these things that are happening in
these countries
I didn't see a lot of families there
there's not a lot a lot of military aged
men all right I'm going to reach the
Syrian migrants remember that the the
refugees yeah and it was less than one
percent of them were actual Christians
when they were fleeing country where if
you were a Christian you were burned
alive or you were thrown off of a
rooftop that was the excuse that they
were and we were bringing in military
aged males who were Muslims a lot of
them Muslim extremists into Europe so
this is what they say to you because hey
why don't you care they're pulling on
the heartstrings yeah right they want
you to think of a mom with three
children that she's trying to kind of
get across the river and that does
happen don't get me wrong so that's not
what this a lot of Venezuelans right now
right a lot of their fleeing oppression
hey Brian uh Gerald let me ask who
Venezuela who who was in charge of
didn't Sean Penn loves Sean Penn said
one of the greatest political leaders of
our time
I know it's isn't it Maduro now yes
Chavez and Maduro because remember they
were praised didn't Bernie Sanders say
breadlines are he was referring to
Venezuela too as he said that's actually
not a bad thing it means they're trying
to ensure equality and now they use
their own enforced equality as uh
justification for it being oppressive
when it doesn't work and then we have to
take them in so much equality we're
we're bursting at the same so much
equality so much equality they're eating
cats they are cats well you know never
has a country before been blessed with
so many resources and been so poor uh as
Venezuela well let me read you the quote
from Washington Post because I'm going
to make fun of them for a second so in
the Mexican border city of Juarez good
for you come back to me please do that
not bad do you know you're an idiot you
just said in the Mexican city of the
city Juarez it just bothers me I'm sorry
you could have just said Juarez crowds
of dust covered family please hold on
this needs to be more serious because
this is the tone crowds of dust covered
families climbed out of rail cars and
headed for the gates in the U.S border
wall
urging U.S agents to allow them in urge
I love it you know what if I'm a border
patrol agent and you keep urging I'm
still probably
I'm probably not gonna
yeah come on in I don't know it's like
is that all it takes they weren't
pleading they were urged a little bit of
urging is that all it takes can we send
that little gremlin from the park in New
York Dad yeah nothing nothing
if a law enforcement agent right is
enforcing the law yeah is that just or
like hey hold on a second hey you just
uh you pickpocketed that man yes officer
but I urge you not to arrest me yeah and
it's hard to say that word without
sounding a little perverted
urge I'm urging to be in your country
that's the Washington Post man this urge
I urge you I explore you implore you get
in your country yeah let's take one more
look around me I urge you to allow me in
I'm
urging and by the way you don't allow
them in it's the vampires you don't
invite them they have to move on that's
fair can we take one more look at the
picture of the uh these migrants yeah I
think overlay F1 look at that um
dust covered families
if anything that one guy there to the
right could use a little Dusty as a bit
of a shiny forehead he does yeah I know
that that happens look Nary a woman or
child to be seen or a matte powder there
you go just matches the skin tone
everything is just covered family
I have record numbers of fentanyl you
have more slaves than ever on earth
right now and then in recorded history
just to be clear 42 million a lot of
them sex slaves just to be clear
trafficked across the border and of
course the little the little overlooked
fact that uh you know your jobs matter
your livelihood matters and there's no
way of knowing there's no way of knowing
if people aren't signing the guest book
what they're doing here and that's we
make all the references available at
letters always we're all a little upset
today because of uh you know the Russell
Brand and the The Invasion going on but
uh I think that we've assembled this and
you have a really good job uh set forth
but just well I just
thank you for setting me forth on my job
look this is a part of a plan you've
seen a lot of stuff out of Italy as well
what is it lamp dusa the island where
they're they're just experiencing crazy
amounts of people coming in I'm gonna
I'm gonna draw you some parallels right
this is not by accident but let me just
give you some information to tell you
just how bad it is right now uh these
numbers are staggering let's let's break
it down for the people break it down so
key fact number one so they can go
forward and uh Know You Better Man the
average number of illegals Crossing by
the way and I'm not gonna say migrants
they're people breaking the law they're
illegal I know that you can't make a
person illegal well if they break the
law and enter the country illegally yes
I can police report says it's up 450 per
month under Joe Biden Trump averaged 41
233 Biden is averaging 179 138 and by
the way on September 17th Alone 7 500
crossed in one day if you put that out
or if that Trend persists which I don't
see any reason why it wouldn't that'd be
000 monthly 7 500 okay if we can't solve
the board of Crisis right now just start
with baby steps put the people in charge
of the turnstile at Six Flags there so
they won't be able to get that much
volume that's fair I think that would be
good 7 500 yeah well and by the way just
just to make sure you understand they're
not fleeing religious persecution by and
large 99.9 of them aren't at least
they're just free fleeing crappy
economies I understand the desire to get
to a better place but there has to be a
process otherwise the better place does
not exist anymore after a certain period
of time but they know this here's
Fastback number two ever hear of
fentanyl the thing that didn't kill
somebody up in the north and caused
riots no just saying it didn't actually
happen I think it was the fentanyl
they're probably good one thing that you
just mentioned I think is very important
where yeah if you're fleeing crappy
economic policies right and it's just
okay now we'll take you in there would
be no incentive to create better
economic policies it's for the same
reason we have 50 Peter we have 50
states here to see okay what works and
what doesn't hey you guys have tried
socialism you guys have tried fascism
totalitarianism we didn't right so so in
other words hey but the left of course
encourages the policies that has led to
Venezuela so there's no there is no
accountability whatsoever it's like no
no our policies have created a better
world a better country for our people
you need to change it in your own
country this is your country and then
you come here we have to hear about your
pride and how Americans don't have
culture well you left yours you left
yours for the culture that created a
place where you could apparently cross
on the tram with a dust covered face so
how about that culture but the left has
no incentive to say no ours is better
because they can't say that ours is
better no but you have to admit that
ours is better but I think that's part
of the plan I really guess it is I think
there's a plan afoot here to try to
create kind of an elite class and then a
very very broad kind of lower class of
people that don't really have any power
and then to have a middle class of
people that's really small and not
represented
that's absolutely what is happening so
here Fentanyl and trafficking they are
absolutely rampant when you don't have
people guarding the Border keeping
people from coming in the 7 500 people a
day do you know how many of those people
are used as drug meals do you know how
many people are being used to get kids
into the United States to traffic
illegally to have sex driving you say
you care about this is a real easy
solution just close the border illegals
by the way they have to pay around like
ten thousand dollars to get into the
United States sometimes it's lower like
2000 you get the Cut Rate coyotes I
guess and then you get like the first
class High rate coyotes that are 10
grand by the way most of those guys
don't have that money they come here
they borrow it from family and then they
have to work to pay it off and a lot of
times it's indentured servitude which is
a lot of the human trafficking that we
talk about this number though shocked me
cartels make right now 13 billion
dollars per year from smuggling people
into the United States that's under
former Vice President Joe Biden anybody
want to take a guess on what that number
was under President Donald Trump
in 2018
500 million no no that's a lot that's
500 million 300 billion to 30. there's
no way billion there's no dollars can
you bring up that reference again can
you bring up that well okay it says
it right there I mean it's not
highlighted I'll give you that yeah but
it's there wow crazy 500 million to 13.
who's a billion dollars a year whose
policies do you think they like better
you think Joe Biden's policies are
actually working better I don't know it
comes down to Brass tax for me and these
guys are making a lot of the brass
fentanyl smuggling is also at an
all-time high 20 to 2020 to 2022 is up
164 this year by the way already up 50
from last year's High wow it's higher
than the high from last time and I'm so
tired I'm sorry of the fentanyl talking
point that you have politicians like we
are the opioids we have a problem no we
don't we don't have an opioid Christmas
we have an illegal drug crisis we have
an illegal opioid credit so the idea
that some kid went in for a you know
went in or some guy went in for a root
canal and became you you know started
blowing people for for a couple of
hydrocodone is completely there's a
problem of fentanyl coming over the
Border no it's absolutely true because
it says opioid
opioid trade-off right two pills for
that maybe get a bottle if you're going
to go that far because when it's
convenient they want to go after a big
Pharma that's the boogeyman right when
the fact is the vast majority of people
who became addicted to prescription
opioids were already addicted to
something else before that and the vast
majority of deaths have come from
illegal opioids like fentanyl like
heroin on the streets and the deaths
went up when prescribing of prescription
opioids went down I'm not saying that
there weren't doctors prescribing
opioids
but what I am saying is they just know
okay we can all just say this because
everyone will be on board they've been
affected negatively but let's not
address the actual problem which is the
13 billion dollars right the open border
because the left benefits from it by the
way the more money and I know they make
a lot of money from drugs but really do
we need to give them more money to
further entrench themselves to further
by politicians to further control these
states and make them crap holes so that
people end up fleeing to the board do
you understand where this is going by
the way stay and make it a better place
that's what you do otherwise this
problem never gets solved stay and make
it a better place it's what we did here
we stayed we made it a better place we
fought Wars to make it a better place
stay in your country fight to make it a
better place so that the Next Generation
or the generation after that doesn't
have to flee and you can stay in your
Homeland and by the way the fentanyl
smuggling that's going on here these
guys are being used for human
trafficking they're being used to
smuggle in drugs you know what the scary
thing really is
smuggling in stuff that's not just drugs
smuggling in I don't know maybe a dirty
bomb are we paying attention to that
maybe there's some sensors that can
catch that stuff smuggling in Al Qaeda
so that they can shoot up a shopping
mall smuggling in somebody who wants to
do us harm Josie Rosenberg one of my
favorite authors wrote a book about this
at the time he does this every freaking
time at the time the Border crisis
starts getting crazy he had written a
book like six months prior to that and
was getting ready to publish it that
talked about them doing exactly that
smuggling in terrorists from the
southern border it is a problem that
needs to be addressed for a myriad of
reasons but yeah but A.G Merrick Garland
had this to say about the smuggling
fentanyl just just don't worry so
Sheriff Mark Daniels from Cochise County
Arizona where you were at a few months
ago and under oath he said the reason
there is such a drastic increase in
fentanyl coming into the country is
because on January 20th of 2021
open borders policies were announced by
President Biden have you expressed
concern about those open borders
policies that have led to this rapid
increase in the amount of fentanyl
coming into our country
I I can't associate myself with the
conclusion reached by the sheriff
that's helpful because
attorney general to draw conclusions no
wow no and from a legal perspective
what's the best thing that we can do
right oh man that just sounds like some
guy on the ground facing the problem
every single day that's just
ill-informed and one thanks a lot doctor
no help yeah
you think he's the villain you walk in
he says nothing like have you been
expecting me mister no no what no Mr
Buck no yeah no oh I'm Dr No oh that's
right no I'm Doctor no help
um I think here's a stat that's really
important that people they'll try and
trick you with this we did we use this
quite a bit in the change in my mind if
you go back and watch the build up the
wall they'll try and say actually
immigrants commit crimes at a lower rate
than natural born citizens ah no one
hears a problem with immigrants we have
a problem with illegal immigrants right
so when you actually uh account for and
it's very hard right to measure that
because they're here illegally which is
kind of the key point is that they
commit violent crimes at a much much
higher rate I don't know if we have
those numbers it would be in the change
of mind I want to say it's it's either 8
or like 16 times higher when you take
people who are here illegally and that's
not just taking into account the fact
that they are here illegally that is in
fact number one but here's something
else when people say oh well you know
what people can't be illegal or okay it
is a much tougher pill to swallow
first off we can get to Sanctuary cities
all that but when your child is shot
in El Paso or your sister is raped by
someone who has a matter of law had no
business being here anyway in other
words that was preventable so you're
trying to Minority Report thought crimes
like Russell Brand right now
but you aren't actually enforcing the
laws that would prevent measurable
quantifiable
violent crimes it's really really hard
to tell someone who had a family member
who was raped or murdered because of a
cartel member because of someone who
came over and just hey I'm not on the
books thought they could get away with
it well I'm really hard to tell them
well you know what though we don't think
that the border is actually the right
way to we don't think that having a
stricter immigration policy will make a
difference let me ask you a question you
think some of these women that are being
trafficked over the Border you think
some of them get raped by these cartel
members of course coyotes how bad does
he want to get your kids across the
border ma'am
yeah exactly so Biden's open border
policy I guess there is there's a
discount if you don't want to spend the
ten thousand dollars I'm sure you can
you can you can negotiate a discount oh
yeah you won't negotiate it because
you'll get raped yeah exactly I mean you
know well I Rave sometime sometimes
sometimes well look that brings us to
fast fact number three
they're doing this on purpose yes this
is all by Design right the Biden
Administration actually removed I don't
know if you saw this story they removed
the the very thing that maybe you want
to keep in place to help solve this
problem razor wire that was put up by
the Texas Nationals we have a clip of
them taking we do then removing
the razors at the border
you know who I am
but you don't know why I'm here oh that
was that was wrong razor a different
razor Guy this is here's the right clip
sorry about that
go
they put steps up in there there you go
guys
hey single file now okay sorry we
haven't built the escalator yet yeah our
bad we'll just get this impediment out
of the way yeah the impediment's there
for a reason yes yes I don't like it
that people get cut up I just would
rather them not come in the first place
and break the law and Governor Abbott
has I think
sometimes he's he is a wheelchair guy
he's not he's not like Chet they didn't
have the thing but he sometimes does
good things sometimes not so much but he
did respond to this on X and I
appreciate him coming out and saying
this he goes Texas installed razor wire
in Eagle Pass to stop illegal Crossings
today the Biden admin cut that wire
opening the floodgates to illegal
immigrants I immediately deployed more
Texas National Guard to repel illegal
Crossings and install more razor wire
good
it should be there and by the way what
the the thing that I have maybe a little
bit of a problem with you governor
governor Abbott you haven't done more on
the border yeah I understand it costs
money we're gonna get to how much it's
actually costing us to have these people
here and why that pressure is starting
to push people you've seen New York
you've seen mayor Adams right now like
oh no oh we have people here and we
can't afford to kind of pay the public
sir guess what it's like to be in a
Border Town why do you think we're
sending them your way right because you
don't feel the pain you just get to look
down on us and go ah just deal with it
guys hiring people the number I remember
back in 2017 I believe is it was 16 uh
billion dollars to build the wall the
highest estimate I think came from NBC
it was like 20 something billion illegal
immigrants back then so not one adjusted
for the uh 542 inflation since then cost
American taxpayers over 110 billion
dollars guess what I have an updated
number for you 150 billion dollars per
year yeah is that just because of in the
services for them yes so here's here's
what happened right so Dem leaders from
Across the Nation whether it's Chicago
San Francisco west coast East Coast New
York what doesn't matter we're sending
them all to you and you get to see what
it's like to help take care of people
when you say hey just deal with it and
take care of people they've been
pressuring the Biden Administration
saying hey you got to do something about
this so the Biden Administration said
that it would Grant nearly half a
million illegal Venezuelans the right to
work in the United States half a million
they're doing it under a program that
was a temporary program put in place in
1990. up until then up until this thing
happened when he granted nearly half a
million people the right to work in the
United States the program had about 220
000 people in it do you understand what
they're doing temporary program and then
they get complaints right they say oh
but won't having a program like this and
giving them this ability to work and
just to be here legally technically at
this point so we can never ever ever
know where they are what they're doing
and actually have them come back out of
the country if they shouldn't be here in
the first place isn't this going to
cause more people to come into no no we
said you had to be here before July 31st
for this to kick in so all those new
people they'll know this isn't going to
happen I'm like
didn't you have that policy in place
before and you just made an exception to
it don't you know they're going to want
you to do that again and they're going
to flood into this country illegally and
hopefully hang around long enough to
vote so that you can do that so that
they can vote so that you can make
another exception you you know
exactly what you're doing and so do the
citizens by the way in Staten Island
those residents they've started
protesting a little bit uh because
they're pissed off for a second night
dozens of protesters rallied outside
Island Shore Senior Center on Staten
Island which is now housing 15 Asylum
seeking families we should be helping
our family this demonstration came
compared to a night earlier when 10
people were arrested including for
assaulting a police
officerately angry the migrant crisis
has reached uh apocalyptic proportions
financially for our city good there you
go that is the most perfectly trimmed
monks cap to beard
that's fantastic that should be that
should be a manscape race yeah it really
bad you know I mean it's brilliant the
Symmetry fantastic good Lord and New
York City is actually fighting in court
to allow
non-citizens to vote which is a
technicality because really when you
don't have voter ID it doesn't matter
anyway yeah we've been saying that that
it's a really good important it's an
important thing to have voter ID but so
let me let me just get this straight so
the Biden Administration is loosening up
the reins on this to bring Venezuelans
here they're doing it by the way at a
time of year when it has the greatest
impact because I don't know if you've
noticed but the weather is starting to
cool down in the South where it's not
quite as hot so more and more people
will feel like okay I can make the
journey I can actually make it there
without dying which is great I
understand that but they're doing it at
the perfect time for that so New York
City's starting to fight this now
they're starting to say hey expand this
temporary program only because it costs
them money that's it that's absolutely
all it is because they can't afford to
do it and now Pennsylvania is
automatically going to register people
to vote when they get their state ID
which they say you don't have to prove
your residency to get no not only that
but we also know for example when people
say oh none of these court cases on the
elections uh no number one well that's
not that's not entirely true first off
and a big part of the complaints is it's
impossible to purge motor rolls it is in
a lot of these states so there are
people who overstay in other words
someone may be able to get a state ID
who is not a natural-born citizen who is
not entitled to vote their visa May
lapse and they can still vote it's
almost impossible we went through that
when we called the Nevada uh sorry Clark
County Registrar in Nevada he said well
we just can't do anything about it if
they've already voted it's done so if we
can't keep dead people from voting
certainly we can't keep migrants from
voting who shouldn't be here and voting
illegally and by the way I know what
you're thinking about the Pennsylvania
thing oh my God Joe Biden was voted for
but let's see uh Joe Lewis the boxer not
the dog Ethel Merman and taco Jimenez uh
19 times Abraham Lincoln I didn't know
he was still around but good for him
yeah right he's probably looking good at
that ripe all day he's hunting vampires
I hear
voters don't even have to prove the
Asian citizenship even though they say
they do and here's why I say that right
so they have a process where they say in
Pennsylvania you're going to have to
prove your age and your citizenship well
that sounds good right there's no audit
process
so so the rule is there and then
somebody comes in and breaks the rule we
have no way of tracking that rule being
broken and so we're just like yeah but
there's a rule so what do you have to
show what well hold on a second there's
no audit can't you just send uh 87 000
new IRS agents yeah new IRS employees
remember that's how they find I'm sorry
IRS employees technically send a third
of those there pencil pushers yes right
one-third of them to audit uh
citizenship as opposed to my Trader
Joe's receipts
yeah yeah I was gonna say what what do
you have to what do you have to show to
get a government ID what id do you have
to show to get a government your tits
you know what I'll let research pull
something up on this but I believe that
there have been several states that are
trying to push for just making sure even
illegal immigrants have IDs State IDs
yes
it's oppression it's privilege they say
they're trying to argue again that voter
ID is racist black people don't think so
and by the way the vast majority of
Hispanic people don't think so but they
say no no it's much harder for them to
procure uh voter IDs and when you say
really for black people they go yeah
most of them are so poor they don't have
cars condescending they're more to know
how to get an ID is what Joe Biden would
say I don't give a rat's ass steal a
bike
do something and look I I kind of
mentioned this off the top a little bit
I did some reading I think I read this
book last year about Europe's problem
with immigration because it seems like
they're doing the exact same thing we're
just we're a little bit behind the curve
Europe has been doing this for quite a
while and we're taking these policies
and implementing them and typically when
you implement like a new policy we do
something new around here we're like all
right well has it been done before about
anybody you know if we're putting a
policy in behind the scenes maybe did it
work for somebody else did it work for
us okay maybe we won't do this these
people know it has failed Europe these
people know that Europe has turned into
a crap hole all the way up into Sweden
and Finland and the UK and France and
Germany in these places they absolutely
100 know and I think you've probably
been reading about it in the news the
the lamdusa thing that I said lamp do I
say or whatever I don't know the island
in the Mediterranean that is part of
Italy that a lot of these people come to
there's 6 000 people that live there
over the last I believe week to 10 days
000 immigrants illegally crossed and are
there now they outnumber the local
population three to one they could
basically run up a flag and say this is
this is our ship now is that right 100
true not making this up you can pull
that up we'll get a fact check from the
the guys there eighteen thousand six
thousand residents on the island by the
way move off the island or get a turret
because it's not a turret gun and a
tower this has been Eric unscrew that
get a ferry yeah no well so this has
been happening to Italy for well over a
decade and this specific island is a
Target because it's really close and so
what you think is okay you have let's
just set up a scenario do you have
something really not so good to the
South we'll say right economies aren't
great hard times for people I hate it
War torn because of that sometimes to
the South to the south of a good economy
right so you've got a good group of
economics in general what's South Africa
oh Africa yeah that's right Africa be
careful sorry a little bit right so they
come in through Greece is one of the
major places that they come into look up
some of the stuff that's going on those
islands especially Lesbos and places
like that yeah stop it not that that's
not what I'm saying what's happening
there we're having serious conversations
and then they go down into Libya they
actually yeah North into Libya and then
come across into the southern part of
Italy do you know what Italy decided to
do when they started to realize we
cannot function well
we're gonna ship them North
they started shipping immigrants North
they would literally give them tickets
to go as far north as they would like to
go and put them on a train guess what
there's no borders there's no borders
now so you can't stop them from going
there now the problem comes and knocking
on your doorstep does that sound
familiar hey guys they're people their
families just fleeing persecution you
should take them in you should pay for
their housing you should do everything
that you can sounds great I'm sending
you a hundred thousand right now ready
ordered hey do it you know before people
get mad about the whole Africa thing
because you know I don't know how you
have an entire it's not a continent
that's never gotten it right
um and I don't by the way that's not
because of melanin for the same reason
it's Venezuela we've talked about this
in South America it's because of ideas
horrible economic policies exactly that
being said right now we're talking about
immigrants right fleeing to Europe right
and going into Italy you know what else
happened there's a lot of North North
Africans and people in the Mediterranean
Coast you guys know how many
people were enslaved by the North
African slave trade they were captured
that's why they had to fortify their
cities I believe someone can bring it up
it's it's the low estimate is at least a
million people were enslaved
specifically in those you guys know
about the history with the Moors and
Sicily but you know about that a lot of
people don't remember North African
slave Traders would capture people white
people you think that all slaves were
black so when I say Africa you think
after those people were slaves white
people own slaves the North African
slave Traders many of whom were black
were capturing white people off the
Mediterranean coast and that I don't
know these there have been estimates as
low as 500 000 and I've seen them as
high as six million let's round it one
million so back then we had North
African uh uh basically let's let's call
them what they are evil people North
African criminals right slave Traders
capturing people across the
Mediterranean because they didn't
protect the borders and now because
they've screwed up their own country so
badly the cradle of civilization also
the Cradle of slavery uh now fleeing to
the places on the same Coast where they
used to kidnap people and by the way the
only line of defense back then against
the slave trade was the British Navy uh
gentlemen very helpful but these people
this this is a parallel right now no it
won't stop until the elite until the
elite leftists have to use them I'm
getting there Brian you just brought up
a cue if we had like the word of the day
one million to one and a quarter million
white slaves wow training costs for them
the North African slave trade yeah a lot
of people don't know that but no they
don't they don't know that they were
kidnapped stolen and they had to build
up that's why they had to build up and
these you can see these structures yeah
yeah you make it a race thing I just
think it's interesting how history
repeats itself they were invading your
Coast to steal your people and now
they're invading your Coast because uh
they want free stuff yeah the elites are
fine with it Brian
until they have to give up their their
second their vacation home they don't
have to give up their stuff that's the
whole point they want you to give up
your stuff yeah I know so what they're
trying to do and this is the exact same
game plan over there
big group of not big group but Elites
they have a lot of money there's a group
of Elites there's a handful of people in
this middle class they say they care
about and then there's a ton of very
very very poor people that's what they
are going for that's exactly what's
happening in Europe as well that's
exactly what happened in Russia every
Communist Regime throughout history and
socialist regime throughout history end
up with Elites and then they end up with
a bunch of people that are completely
dependent on them that don't really have
a whole lot but at least they have that
Daily Bread line to go stand in that
Bernie Sanders says was a good thing let
me really quickly just tell you though
with all of these people fleeing North
Africa and going into Europe through
Italy the Italian Prime Minister giorgia
Meloni noted the battle against
immigration is an apocal battle for
Italy and Europe
sorry
it's an epic battle bro all right bro
it was just that was a that was a fake
question for our viewers who aren't as
uh bombastic so that must mean he
volunteered as tribute
laughs
[Music]
at the same time Texas is being invaded
by illegals the exact same thing is
happening in Italy both are results
results of you know not just bad
policies this is exactly the kind of
policy that they want at the federal
level both in Washington and the
European Union that Washington seems to
want to copy both Abbott and Maloney are
people that are on the front lines
having to deal with all of these
situations and pay out the nose for it
and they start to send immigrants to the
north so that they can figure out how
this is actually affecting us here
locally and see if they like it and
people are finally starting to take
notice so Texas is Italy
I think that's right I think Texas is
absolutely Italy and I think we should
not stop sending people North until the
problem is addressed 150 billion dollars
a year is what we pay out I think we can
afford the 16 billion dollars to secure
the Border look comment has you had any
personal experience with illegal
immigration in your community have you
felt unsafe in your community because
they're illegal immigrant by the way
doesn't mean that these people are
criminals they did break the law to get
here so they're criminal in that sense
I'm saying they're not necessarily more
likely to be more stabby stabberton to
you but when they are in the dark
economy when they don't have the
protection of being able to call the
police they have to form their own units
for protection that typically takes the
form of a gang when a gang is in a
community you typically feel less safe
because the gang is going to do what the
Gang has to do to survive that's the
problem but guess what we have a plan
from Senor Donald Trump he has got a
good plan I think it is the best plan
can you please you got to help me with
it it's it's a look I've got a plan the
best plan there won't be a situation
here like the Moors there won't be
Sicilian here though they got great
ditch
Donald Trump when speaking in Iowa I
don't know why people still go to Iowa
for this stuff like that no offense
Iowans but you don't matter that you're
gonna need a knife when you get to the
corns
absolutely the Trump and the corn so
he wanted to uh do the largest
deportation operation in American
history upon my inauguration I will
immediately terminate every open borders
policy of the Biden Administration we'll
get it back
and follow the
Dwight D Eisenhower model so Eisenhower
was very tough on the border people
don't see him as that but he was we'll
carry out the largest domestic
deportation operation in American
history
foreign
immediately the alien enemies act to
remove all known or suspected gang
members
it's the first time I've heard Donald
Trump self-censor himself not like this
post on true social though let's find
them back on a bang bus look at that new
border security will work for food
I love it he did that he posted that
it's not a joke but guess what he also
had more comments he wanted to
militarize the Border I will shift
massive portions of federal law
enforcement to immigration enforcement
including parts of the DEA ATF FBI and
DHS all of them you know and I'll make
clear that we must use any and all
resources needed to stop The Invasion
including moving thousands of troops
currently stationed overseas guarding
other people's borders we guard other
people's borders but we don't go out our
own think of it think of it save lives
that's an appropriate role for the
military four Libertarians come in and
just and I used to be one to be clear
this is an appropriate role it involves
American Security legal City and by the
way remember when we did the change of
mind there was one lady from a sanctuary
City who barely spoke English and she
talked about being in an area with a lot
of illegal immigrants who were
committing crimes and she was afraid
that she couldn't actually really report
them to the police it was a whole
situation where she was really terrified
because they would threaten the family
so people who are here legally and this
is something you can go and watch if you
I think we've cataloged all that on on
Rumble but certainly on YouTube changed
my mind build a wall you'll see it uh we
had to blur her face these people
struggle with this on a daily basis and
we actually Donald Trump talking about
the military I mean it might seem severe
we have an exclusive inside look we do a
border brainstorming session I'm
suggesting we put these electronic
collars on all the deportees then we
bury a wire along the border forming an
invisible fence now the next time this
is illegal tries to enter the country
okay
how
much more effective yeah he was in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off so uh Trump
also wanted to do something
controversial which was reinstating the
travel ban oh no he's known for I will
bring back the travel ban and expand it
even further to keep radical Islamic
terrorists out of our country look how
it worked for four years look how it
worked it worked so incredibly yeah and
by the way the numbers back it up he's
not he's not a numbers guy when he but
he just what he said is absolutely
because he's 100 and this is assuming
that everything he says is something he
will follow through on yes that being
said no one else is being as aggressive
at least even in their rhetoric at this
point and nobody did more during their
time in presidency to actually solve
this problem every single president that
I have known in my lifetime has been
been told like hey we have a problem at
the border we have a problem at the
border and they have been kicking the
can down the road and not doing anything
one final point he actually wanted to
deny uh entry to uh uh people we don't
like at all marxists I will also use
existing federal law to deny entry for
to all Communists and marxists to the
United States we have people coming in
Deport College professors known
marketers known fascists and they're
coming into the United States and we
don't want them we got enough of them I
mean we have enough of them in Congress
we have enough of them in our own
Congress I told him we've already got
one and it's a very nice well he said
radical islamists how much do you want
to bet that the mainstream media will
take out the words radical and just say
we don't want islamists yeah that's what
that's what will happen no it absolutely
will look this is by Design they're
eliminating the middle class like I've
told you they're creating this ruling
class of people that is the only way you
can survive as a lower just look at
Russia it's the same exact thing bread
lines bunch of people living in
fantastic wealth and it is absolutely
imperative that we do everything
possible to get a republican in office
in 2024 and they have to follow up with
what they say about the border the
border is one of the most pressing
issues I know there are big issues out
there this is one of the most pressing
issues and it is economics the border is
economics I know everybody goes to the
inflation we go to the stuff that we've
talked about in your dollar not going as
far not making as many of those dollars
and not being able to get a house
because of the interest rates and all
that stuff this affects the economy as
well and this is how you get the
Suburban mom demographic back into the
fold which we've had a problem with in
the Republican party for quite a while
you get this problem solved and it can
actually be fantastic so look don't
forget tomorrow we do have the live show
featuring exclusive behind the scenes
content we've actually been doing a lot
of behind the scenes stuff some pretty
pretty hilarious behind the scenes
depends sometimes depending we'll see
and it can only be seen on the wonderful
place known as Mud Club here's a little
bit of a taste experiences
Within
listening so I guess we go down a rise
of big boob positivity there was there
was negativity
they're candy
they like interview the one guy who's
like everyone hate boobs
who I couldn't help but picture in the
back of my mind as the many that Nick de
Palo saw in my raw Shack test
that's perfect I can't top that maybe I
could do a Herzog thing where it's like
this was all just one big glorified
documentary I invited him to pleasure my
himself with great Vigor in the deal
she don't have like purple rings under
your eyes
oh yeah
is this from trolls four
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's no respect in this generally it
really is not any at all wait filming
run through is a bad idea yeah yeah yeah
absolutely we deleted all the
run-throughs we have a little fun we
like to have it it's like cancel Blood
Brothers though because you're really
going down with it yeah you all every
single person you absolutely do but look
if you want to see stuff like that or if
you want to see Nick depalo if you want
to see Alex Jones if you want to see the
Hodge twins or if you want to see Brian
Callan here in his show that's out right
now if you want to see Mr guns in gear
in the Friday show and all the extra
promo and then specials that are coming
undercover stuff that's coming if you
want to support us join mug Club right
now 89 annually go to
ladderwithcrowder.com or or better yet
there's a little button I think it's
over here if I remember correctly it's
right about
hit that button and join mug Club you
can keep watching and get the rest of
the show today we're doing a full
additional show I went a little long I
apologize I got a little long-winded
over here can I say it we like can I say
the last part because
right exactly
I'll be in Waukegan Illinois this Sunday
ladies and gentlemen uh at seven o'clock
um boom about 35 miles outside of
Chicago Brian callan.com go there and
see when he's performing in a city near
you it is worth at least a five minute
drive to go and see him absolutely worth
every minute of the drive you like
laughing hard for an hour
who is a big breast negative yes there's
one guy out there it's like I hate boobs
and I hate laughing all right you can
say that I'm not a boob guy
piss off YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign